goofy corny lazy and awful why are some
fans using these words to describe Black
Adam Dwayne Johnson's Black Adam has
struck theaters in full force with a
charismatic Hollywood Powerhouse finally
lending his talents to a superhero
franchise as Johnson's 15-year passion
project the star tried to make a film
that pleased fans of the DC Universe and
fans of the Black Adam character to
Johnson's credit the film is doing
surprisingly well in user review sites
like IMDb and holds impressive audience
scores on both Metacritic and Rotten
Tomatoes this could be a sign that Black
Adam genuinely resonated with bands
though it's also worth noting that user
review platforms are ripe for outside
exploitation that said the film has not
done well with a critical Community as
well as viewers outside superhero fan
spaces while issues range from the story
to the acting a number of online users
have United over one thing the film's
supposedly terrible dialogue here we go
on the movie subreddits reddit's most
outspoken cinephiles have taken to the
comment section to offer their scavian
opinions of the film's dialogue one user
said the dialogue was so bad so bad like
if you've had an AI every comic book and
comic book movie this is what it would
regurgitate
another wrote the dialogue was terrible
and cheesy I didn't feel any of the
jokes landed I think a more serious
route would have done this movie a lot
of good even those who felt the movie
had other strong points found their
experience hindered by the dialogue one
user said Pierce Brosnan and his doctor
Fates and some of the action sequences
make this passable but dear Lord the
dialogue was awful another who claimed
the movie was otherwise alright
described the dialogue as tryhard while
another said the movie was fine but
still disliked the dialogue one simply
stated the dialogue sucks even Twitter
joined in on the party with users
dunking on the movie's unimpressive
writing one Twitter user equipped that
I'm not a good guy is half of Dwayne
Johnson's dialogue in Black Adam
rules don't kill people well I do
another wrote holy crap the dialogue in
Black Adam is atrocious
really use a superhero right about now
I'm no hero meanwhile sports reporter
Wyatt wheeler called the dialogue laugh
out loud terrible and another claimed it
had some of the cringiest dialogue in
any comic book movie which is quite a
bold claim considering Batman vs
Superman still exists
other words hurled at the dialogue were
goofy lazy generic and corny Rolling
Stones David fear wrote a hilarious and
subtle backhanded diss at the film's
dialogue saying Black Adam has it all
actors opening and closing credits sound
dialogue some on the other hand forbes's
Scott mendelsohn found the dialogue to
be amusing referring to the film as a
whole as refreshing the unassuming and
divorced from the discourse just a fun
three-star tentpole of course fans can
make up their own minds by checking out
Black Adam which is in theaters now
[Music]